Avanza en el congreso de los diputados
el debate de la moción de censura contra
el presidente del gobierno de España
Pedro Sánchez impulsada por el partido
ultraderechista vox una iniciativa
abocada al fracaso que ha sido
calificada de Absurda de show
parlamentario o de pantomima por los
distintos actores políticos pese a esto
la sesión lleva ya más de 7 horas en la
cámara baja española el objetivo de vox
con esta iniciativa es adelantar las
elecciones generales previstas para
finales de año al 28 de mayo cuando se
celebren comicios municipales y
autonómicos en España las razones que
esgrimen para esta moción ilícito
textualmente son acabar con una
legislatura suicida y van desde la
reforma del Código Penal hecha por el
gobierno que suprimió el delito de
sedición o rebajó las penas por
malversación a la aprobación de la ley
transpando por también la baja tasa de
natalidad en el país todas estas razones
las han expuesto tanto Santiago abascal
el presidente del partido vox
Como Ramón tamames candidato propuesto
por la ultraderecha para tomar las
riendas del ejecutivo si esta moción de
censura sale adelante él es una
economista de 89 años que ha ido mirando
en las últimas décadas hacia la derecha
desde las filas del partido comunista de
España la votación se hará mañana
miércoles pero se espera que solo reciba
el sí de los 52 diputados de vox en el
congreso muy lejos de los 176 necesarios
para que la moción de censura salga
adelante